Speaker 1: So hang Mike Pence. Hang Mike
Pence was a rallying cry. It was a chant that
was relevant and prevalent on January six, 2021.
Congressman Aguilar, during yesterday's hearings,
said that a court filing indicates that
a proud boys informant confessed to the
FBI. If the Proud Boys had been able
to get near Mike Pence on January 6th,
they would have killed them. It wasn't just
rhetoric hang Mike Pence. The plan was kill
them if we get the opportunity. We later
learned that they actually did get the mob
got to within 40 feet of Vice President
Mike Pence at the time. Check this out.
Speaker 4: Make no mistake about the fact
that the vice president's life was in danger.
A recent court filing by the Department of
Justice explains that a confidential informant
from the Proud Boys told the FBI the proud boys
would have killed Mike Pence if given a chance.
This witness whom the FBI affidavit refers to
is one. Wright stated that other members of the
group talked about things they did that day, and
they said that anyone they got their hands on they
would have killed, including Nancy Pelosi. One
further stated that members of the Proud Boys said
that they would have killed Mike Pence if given a
chance. We understand that congressional leaders
and others were evacuated from the Capitol
complex during the attack. We'd like to show
you what happened after the vice president was
evacuated from the Senate. Select Committee has
obtained never before seen photos from the
National Archives that show Vice President
Pence sheltering in a secure underground
location. His rioters overwhelmed the Capitol
at 4:19 p.m.. Vice President Pence is seen
looking at a tweet. The president had just sent
a tweet asking the rioters to leave the
Capitol. After four and a half hours
spent on working to restore order, the vice
president returned to the Senate floor to
continue the certification of electors.
Speaker 1: So had they been able to get
their hands on him, they would have
killed them. And then you, of course,
have we knew what would happen. Fox News trying to
run interference. Here is John Roberts on Fox News
saying, well, you know, this wasn't really
that dangerous. We subsequently learned
that the mob came within 40 feet of Mike Pence.
Speaker 3: Let me get your thoughts about this
threat against the vice president, because some of
the protesters who were there on January the sixth
erected a gallows outside of the Capitol building.
Now, it's not to say that the vice president would
have ever gotten near those gallows unless, of
course, the mob was successful in finding him as
he was in the bowels of the Capitol building.
Speaker 1: Right. Well,
they ultimately came within 40 feet there.
Speaker 3: There were concerns for his safety.
Absolutely. On that day.
Speaker 2: There sure were. And I think
we're going to hear about that, John. I mean,
when you go back to that day and you remember
and we're going to see images of
the video of the vice president
being ushered down the stairs there. Marc
Short. Marc Short was with and Greg Jacob,
who we've been hearing from throughout the
morning, was with him as well. These were very,
very unnerving moments. And the protester
video and what they're saying on it,
quote, If Pence caves, we will drag him
through the streets is very, very unnerving,
very unsettling stuff for any American.
Speaker 3: Yeah. I mean, there's there's there's
no question that the protesters were riled up and
at least articulating their desire to do violence
if if a certain outcome did not come to pass.
Speaker 1: Right. And we subsequently learned
that it was within 40 feet, 40 feet of coming
to pass, that the mob would reach Pence. So
incredible revelations. And, you know, there's
been a lot of hemming and hawing about,
oh, the ratings are enough people watching
or whatever the case may be. We have to think
about these hearings as are they indicative of a
necessary criminal referral for whoever, for maybe
multiple people. And legal experts increasingly
are watching these hearings and saying that the
answer is yes. Now, the Justice Department has
said, we're watching. We're certainly paying
attention. Whether it will come to pass that there
are criminal proceedings, criminal charges for any
individuals about whom we learn during these
hearings remains a question mark. But there is no
shortage here whatsoever. And many of the folks
involved correctly now needing criminal attorneys.
Let me know what you believe will be the outcome
here. Find me on Twitter at David Pakman. We'll
take a break and be right back. The David Pakman
Show is made possible by members who sign up at
join pack mccolm. We don't have a money tree or
a coin plant of any kind out in the backyard. We
depend on people who sign up at join
Packman dot com. You get instant access
to the bonus show of course, as well as commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show. You also
get The Daily Show 5 to 6 hours earlier than
nonmembers. Isn't that great? You can sign up at
join Packman dot com with the coupon
code. Big voting 22. Big voting 22.